[Music]
so
[Music]
it is seven o'clock good to see you this
morning as g7 leaders prepare for a
virtual conference president biden is
weighing up whether or not to give that
kabul airlift operation more time or
pull out all us troops from afghanistan
by the end of the month
uh in just a moment we'll be speaking to
the defense secretary ben wallace does
he believe that the prime minister
can convince the president to stay just
a little longer also ahead this morning
uh we'll be taking a look ahead to the
opening ceremony of the paralympic games
in tokyo and indeed assessing team gb's
chances with the paralympian and wafula
strike that at half past nine it's
tuesday the 24th of august
the prime minister is expected to use g7
talks to try to convince president biden
to extend the evacuation effort in kabul
past the 31st of august
a perilous journey sky news films the
afghan citizens given a route to safety
as the hours tick down on the airlift
operation
this is their
flight out of kabul it's been horrendous
for them and are on the way to new lives
it's um for them i think it's
a dream i suppose but i think getting to
this point has been horrendous for all
of them
for the afghan staff who aided britain's
work in afghanistan we hear of their
hopes for their new lives here
i pick up the gun and shorted taliban
myself
to save britain's
so
i think it's their turn to help me and
my family
right
also this morning the home office
reports a new daily record for migrant
crossings with
828 people intercepted on saturday alone
good morning for many of us the weather
has at last settled down a lovely subtle
spell of weather with high pressure
meaning fine days lots of dry weather
lots of sunshine and feeling a little
bit warmer as well i'll bring you all
the details later on
[Music]
morning all the prime minister will
chair an emergency meeting of g7 nations
today what is expected to try to
persuade president biden to delay the
31st of august deadline for the
afghanistan withdrawal allowing more
time for the evacuation efforts on the
eve of the summit a u.s official
suggested that president biden would
decide today whether or not to stick to
that withdrawal date despite the uk
pushing for more time sky news was told
by the taliban that the agreed date for
the pull-out is a red line and that
there will be
repercussions if it's exceeded our
foreign affairs editor deborah haynes
has our first report
u.s forces running kabul airport are
running out of time
[Music]
unless their president decides in the
coming hours to delay his troops
departure date beyond next tuesday
they'll soon need to pack up
once that happens the uk other allies
and this whole evacuation effort will
have to follow
boris johnson is set to use a virtual
meeting of g7 powers to find unity after
days of friction
in a statement he said
our first priority is to complete the
evacuation of our citizens and those
afghans who've assisted our efforts over
the last 20 years
but as we look ahead to the next phase
it's vital we come together as an
international community and agree a
joint approach for the longer term
it means for those desperate to leave
right now
they're living on borrowed time the
prime minister is expected to urge joe
biden to keep his forces in afghanistan
a few days more but any extension would
preferably need buy-in from the taliban
too and they've told sky news august the
31st isn't just a deadline it's a red
line stay longer and there will be
consequences in washington biden's
national security adviser was asked
about the warning
we are in talks with the taliban on a
daily basis through both political and
security channels i'm not going to get
into the details of those discussions
here to protect those discussions which
are covering a wide range of issues
there's also a growing terrorist threat
the longer the evacuation goes on
it all makes for a chaotic exit that's
straining the uk's special relationship
with the united states
they do care about what the uk thinks
and also other allies
and i think that the u.s military cares
very much about what the uk military
thinks they work closely on the ground
and and that will have some bearing on
what president biden um
decides
it's a matter of life and death for
those waiting to hear when the last
flight will be
debra haynes sky news
very pleased to say the defense actor
ben wallace joins us once again on the
programme minister good to see you this
morning and of course a lot for us to
discuss in terms of the g7
but i wonder if we can start with with
the operation
on the ground in kabul at the moment can
you just give us the latest on operation
pitting the numbers evacuated and
quite how close we might come to just
getting everyone out of the country
well we're not going to get everyone out
of the country i've been consistent uh
throughout the last few weeks on that
the good news however is that we have
evacuated over 2 000 people in the last
24 hours
that's another 700 extra than we did
last 24 hours
uh it means we evacuated eight thousand
six hundred people since
uh the beginning of this in august of
fourteen said indeed over ten thousand
so we've broken the ten thousand barrier
since april of all the arak british
nationals and other entitled personnel
to come out the country that is a
significant piece of work
we have our flow
of aircraft steady we have availability
and the challenge is really getting
people to the airport
to the processing center and then taking
onto the plane but so that the key thing
is the flow of people
into the airport and some of that is not
within our control that's getting
through taliban checkpoints uh that is
the journey
from kabul to the airport and then
finally when they get there
uh there's about for example 3000 people
outside the british
controlled gate or the british u.s
control gate uh
where we need to have a flow that's
constant to allow people in
and there's some nearly 15 000 people
around the whole airport so all of that
is the big challenge
just in terms of the security situation
uh are in and around campbell there but
of course we have seen our armed forces
performing their humanitarian duties but
they are there in a security capacity as
well
just how much of a threat do we think
there is in and around the airport at
the moment particularly perhaps
from terrorist attack al-qaeda islamic
state or or other kind of groups that
may well be affiliated or arriving in
country and afghanistan
well
certainly as we get closer to the
deadline of the 31st of august which i
you know i know at the g7 there will no
doubt be a discussion about whether that
is possible to move but the taliban were
pretty clear yesterday
uh that as we get closer to the deadline
i think this it's correct to say that
the security risk goes up it just gets
more and more dangerous
as sort of add-on groups and other
terrorist groups such as isis would like
to to be seen
to take greater credit or like to be
seen
to chase the west at the airport that is
inevitably going to feed their narrative
and their their ambitions uh the taliban
actually are controlling the outer ring
off the airport and indeed checkpoints
throughout kabul that makes it harder
for isis terrorists and the taliban and
isis have uh no friendly relationship at
all but yeah we are very mindful that
we're very very
uh vulnerable or should uh these
terrorists choose to do something and
that's why the bravery of our soldiers
and indeed you know of of many of those
people from other nations doing that job
is is amazing they are literally
out there amongst uh very very desperate
people uh and the situation could get
more insecure so that's why we're trying
everything we can to prioritize people
and get them through
how quickly could we get out of the
country if if we needed to do so i know
from conversations i've had with a
couple of people who are on the ground
in kabul that
there are real concerns about the
prospect of perhaps even a suicide
bomber coming close to the garden
well we have lots of methods you know
you could obviously
seal the gates you could obviously
put yourself behind barriers that would
make it even harder to process
members of the arab scheme or indeed
other entitled personnel and that's a
very
difficult uh choice that that our men
and women of our armed forces have to
make literally every minute which is
where do i put myself in order to help
this humanitarian crisis so
there are obviously steps you can do
there's also the issue of you know of
course we could leave
in a hurry if we had to but of course
the trade-off there is how much
equipment do we leave behind
how many more people do we leave behind
and that's why we are working every
minute to try and go to the very last
minute and to take both people out and
then take our own personnel out
indeed and uh and of course the question
becomes just when that that last minute
may be we understand of course that the
prime minister and uh other allies at
the around the g7 table will be
attempting to lobby the u.s president
today to perhaps push past the 31st of
august but you know given that which we
heard from skye's interview with the
taliban yesterday about it being a red
line it seems pretty unlikely that there
will be any shift
i i think it is unlikely um
not only because what the taliban has
said but also if you look at the public
statements of president biden
i think it is an unlikely it is
definitely worth us all trying and we
will
uh and we've also changed internally
within our own military system uh how
quickly it could take for us to get out
because for every hour we can squash the
military evacuation is an hour we can
add on to help the civilian evacuation
and that and that's that those are the
tough choices that myself and admiral
ben keys the
chief
commander of of the whole operations of
joint operations have to take which is
you know equipment people uh afghans and
you know making sure all of that is done
wrapped around safe and secure security
for the people on the ground
reports this this morning minister
indeed i believe mps were briefed on it
yesterday uh that we have collected
people from afghanistan that were on uh
the no-fly list can you just tell us a
little bit more about that there seems
to be some confusion one person was on a
no-fly list
made it to the united kingdom but the
assessment at this end was that they
they didn't pose a security risk
well yes so two things
people sort of wonder why we don't just
effectively open the gates in kabul and
let everyone on on a flight and one of
the reasons is that we securely uh
screen them we you know we take their
identity we check against our databases
and we do our very best to minimize uh
any risk to the united uh kingdom should
those people come back but of course
those the proportion of people that crop
up on that is absolutely tiny
and then they usually get extra checks
or indeed in some cases they get
rejected and you know i've i have read
in the media some cases of people who
are rejected
and i can't publicly say why but i know
that they were not rejected for the
reasons they often give the media and so
we have to do that and that is you know
quite rightly that's what we have to be
held to account for um i mean i think
what you can say about this particular
case and i don't know the details of the
individual but what i can say having
been the security minister is two things
one is uh that
it worked i mean that the watch the
watch list or the no-fly list pinged and
the individual was identified so that
that is a a plus sign that it worked uh
and that despite the fact they came
through unconventional routes
effectively you know from afghanistan on
a military flight onto the uae and then
back to the uk
uh the system kept a time of them and i
think that that is that that's something
that other countries very often don't
have so that's a plus the second thing
is and i can't give you too much detail
because of operational security but
we call it generically the no-fly list
but it it has many sub-divisions i mean
it could be this individual and this is
speculation about this particular
individual but it could be it's no fly
until they're checked it could be
uh you know the lots of different
conditions before they fly it's not
necessarily you are that dangerous you
can't come on airplane it may be just
check who they're flying with uh before
they get on a plane so i can't speculate
on this particular
individual but but i think that's why
you saw the home office statement saying
on further examination the individual
himself uh i think was
able to proceed so i i don't think i
would take the same alarm and i i'm
saying i wouldn't i wouldn't
you know i wouldn't pretend otherwise
having done three years of security
minister plus watched on a daily basis
often reports about people whether
they're pinged or not i wouldn't be as
alarmed as some of the media headlines
are about this individual and i would
also take some comfort that this process
is working and flagging people
um minister i wonder if we can turn our
attention to a story that appears to
have emerged over the past few hours
regarding the former royal marine uh
penn farthing he of course operating at
an animal charity in uh in afghanistan
he claims having raised half a million
pounds to to repatriate himself staff
and animals that that flight has been
blocked by by the ministry of defense
what's the truth in all of this
well
so first of all i i've listened to this
and look
penn farthing is a british possible
holder and has done an amazing thing in
kabul he he was offered a flight out i
think last friday or certainly he was
called forward to the airport for
processing his own wife i think left
about the same time
and exited the country and that is our
strong advice to him is to
leave the country um no one is blocking
the charter flight that people have
raised money
other than the fact it this is not about
flights on the ground and whether or not
penn can get on the flight this is
simply not about you know if that
aircraft flew in today it would probably
sit there it would block the airfield it
would sit there empty because it's about
getting as i said earlier the flow
through
the gate through the barriers and into
uh the airport and onto the aircraft it
there's a confusion and and i i think
i'm afraid some of the campaigners have
you know latched on to the fact they've
charted a plane as this somehow is the
magic wand the magic wand is where the
people can get through kabul through the
taliban checkpoint
and then through the 3 000 plus people
waiting
some of whom are waiting in front of the
queue because they are under real threat
direct threat uh right now from taliban
children families we've seen it on your
own amazing reporting i watched your
reporters report first thing this
morning
and you know i'm not prepared to
prioritize for example pets over people
i i want people to come through that
flow so this is not about whether you've
got a chartered aircraft it's not about
that capacity i just got off the phone
from admiral ben kia
joint commander of the whole operation
this is simply about
could he get through the gates or could
his people get through the gates now he
could get through the gates the british
passport holder he was called forward on
friday and i recommend he takes that
his workforce have been offered
as entitled personnel
places and they will be able to be
called forward but i cannot guarantee
that in this window they will be
processed onto aircraft all i can say is
that they qualify
and i as i've said not everyone will get
through as for the animals that he is
rescued and saved it is just not going
to be the case and i will prioritize
them
over the men women and children that we
see in desperate need at the gate you
know i regret that but i don't believe
that uh you know that the taliban's main
point of target will be his workforce
and indeed his
his the the pets and the animals he is
looking after compared to some of those
other people desperate in front of the
queue
sure but minister the the argument that
is made by mr farthing is that this
operation this airlift was okayed by
downing street was okayed by the prime
minister is is that just not the case
then no i i i i i
first of all um i i'm not sure pam
father has been well advised by his uk
based advisor dominic dyer who i saw a
rant on twitter from him and he has been
incredibly abusive to a range of people
including
my advisor first of all my advisor does
not make decisions on who comes in and
out of airports
that is totally misleading to suggest he
could block anything uh i make decisions
as does admiral ben key and my senior
military advisor leaders as does the
foreign office who manage the entitled
personnel list
so that is just a misleading and totally
wrong and i think if pen pen understands
that then maybe he won't be making some
of the things that i've heard him say
today
no one has blocked the plane other than
the fact it is not about a plane flying
in an aircraft uh in the middle of a
military evacuation one of the biggest
military evacuations
of all time is not
a going to help the situation and b is
not the issue
if there were places on our plane
and they could get through
the queues and they could be processing
time and that's the key could they get
through the gate uh
is not about the plane then of course
they will be on those flights he has
been told
that his people and him are eligible to
resettle in the uk as a british passport
holder so is he but but frankly my day
job and my evening job and my night job
is focusing on those thousands of people
outside the front gate he's been offered
a place last friday he was called
forward i strongly recommend he does
that
and you know
once the evacuation is over
i genuinely believe that his workforce
and if he wants to repatriate the pets
that he looks after and the the strays
i genuinely believe that they will be
allowed to move forward
after you know at a later date when that
airport opens but you know frankly i
have to prioritize people at the moment
over pets
mr wallace good to have you on the
program this morning thanks for joining
us thank you thank you
now still to come on the show well uh
you just had to mention the quarter two
uh we'll be turning our attention to
penn farthing the animal sanctuary owner
who says that he and his staff have been
let down by the government as they
remain stuck in kabul a position as you
just heard
roundly rebutted
by the defence secretary
20 past eight i'll be speaking to a
former eu ambassador to the united
states to find out what he thinks the
virtual g7 meeting on afghanistan will
actually achieve
[Music]
and i'll be speaking with the tv
presenter and comedian patty mcginnis
about his new documentary autism and our
family coming your way at 25 to 10.
uh no it is the decision which could
make the difference between life and
death for people trying to flee
afghanistan later today boris johnson
will try to persuade the u.s president
to extend his deadline for withdrawing
troops beyond next tuesday to allow
evacuations to continue our chief
correspondent stuart ramsey has this
report from kabul airport with
special access to the british rescue
operation to get desperate afghans to
safety
they're loaded into trucks and vans
their journeys started days ago but this
is the beginning of perhaps the most
important drive they'll ever take
this is the convoy that takes the latest
evacuees to the kabul main airport to
board a flight to the uk
through the gates of the compound where
their status has been checked and
confirmed back into the territory of the
taliban and the wilderness of the
thousands waiting for news
to the right in a sewage canal a holding
pen for people who might have the right
paperwork
this isn't the hopeless line this is the
hopeful line but it's utterly awful
they head on through the soldiers of
multiple countries looking for people
with a right to enter
then beyond away from the queues
passing those who have been successful
but are now living in what look like
refugee camps
everywhere looks like a refugee camp in
a disaster movie
but this is reality
suddenly it's left behind
inside the wire now and the start of
processing before boarding
a search dog to come out and just do a
quick search
you will then get your bags back
all the travelers have their bags
checked they're allowed one piece each
the uk forces are trying to make it feel
like they're on an ordinary flight
conscious how much trauma every single
passenger has endured this isn't about
getting masses of people herding them
together and getting them onto planes
everything is about making sure we
remember that these are our friends
they're people that have worked with us
for years and we treat them in that way
so it's about being dressed like this as
much as possible it's about showing them
that we're not scared it's about making
sure that the children are fed that
babies are looked after that anything we
can do to reduce their stress levels and
show them that they're safe
is at the heart of what we do here
amongst the evacuees are five-year-old
twins asner and
sana they're with their mum dad and
brother
the first time twins have been spotted
by the raf
this is the start of their new life
although everything is clearly very
strange
dad naraga was a uk military translator
in helmand
this flight will save his life for
certain
getting here was terrifying i used to be
as a interpreter with british
engineers
and do you think the taliban would have
killed you
yes no doubt
yes
this was like everybody was scared
that's what they're going to do
and the first time they're telling three
people that's we're gonna do nothing for
everybody
but nobody knows
they're going to repeat the same thing
like in 1996.
the runway and apron are now at full
flow this evacuation effort has to be
thousands have been moved even more need
to be but time is running out
behind the enormous transporter planes
rows of people wait to board buffeted by
the backwash of propellers and jet
engines
lines of people are brought through and
positioned awaiting instructions from
the loaders
this is a huge operation
but it's still probably not enough
the latest british flight boards the
passengers guided up the loading ramps
seating them along the sides before
being directed into rows and secured for
the flight
this is only the second time in raf
history that they've actually
used
cargo ropes to a seat belt on the floor
the last time within southern sudan
there's 130 people on this flight plus
cargo but this is their
flight out of kabul it's been horrendous
for them and we're on the way to new
lives it's um for them i think it's
a dream i suppose but i think getting to
this point has been horrendous for all
of them
asner sana and their family are on board
they have no plans yet other than to
move to southern england where they
believe the weather is better
after what's happened to their lives in
a week
just worrying about the weather
has got to feel great
stuart ramsey sky news kabul
i had those clearly the lucky ones uh
let's speak once again to our
correspondent sally lockwood
joining us at from qatar sally good to
see you again i mean that that august
31st date looming large in everyone's
minds no more so than those outside
kabul international airport but you know
following on from your interview
yesterday picked up by the world's media
with uh with the taliban leadership i
mean it doesn't look likely does it
well certainly it doesn't appear
advisable the taliban spokesperson who
sat down with us here in doha certainly
emphatic in his warning that that 31st
of august deadline set by the biden
administration to have all troops out of
the country is a red line and staying
beyond that
would have consequences of course stuart
showed there the extraordinary effort
being carried out by the british
military alongside uh the americans and
other foreign forces having to turn
their hands to this humanitarian crisis
that has unfolded at kabul airport a
crisis of political making that they are
now having to clear up with just days to
go thousands more people still desperate
to be evacuated in that time just a week
to go
and of course let's not forget they also
have to evacuate themselves
safely
and with this deadline fast approaching
politicians are still somehow debating
whether it should or shouldn't be
extended we are expecting president
biden to perhaps make his thoughts clear
on this at the g7
meeting of leaders later we're hearing
that boris johnson will appeal to
president biden to extend this deadline
if he hasn't already and of course uh
the humanitarian crisis that is
unfolding is is still something that we
will see continue beyond the 31st of
august deadline so what then what then
for humanitarian agencies who need
access what then for potentially any
more people who need airlifted out of
the country how how will they get access
to a flight i should say that it it was
an extraordinary airlift effort by the
americans yesterday airlifting 10 000
people out of kabul in a 24-hour period
they've certainly ramped up that pace we
expect that pace to continue but they
will need to allow themselves days to
evacuate the 6 000 troops on the ground
as well and let's not forget there are
just days left
indeed sally many thanks
uh now let's take a run through some of
today's other main stories now and a
record 825 migrants were intercepted
across the english channel on saturday
and that's the highest daily figure that
we've seen this year it surpasses the
previous record for a single day which
was 592 in fact recorded just a little
earlier this month
a fire caused by an illegal sky lantern
has taken hold in a nature reserve in
brazil six people have been arrested in
connection with the blaze at franco de
russia in sao paulo
more than 13
500 firefighters are working to contain
a series of wildfires that have
destroyed hundreds of homes and forced
thousands of people to flee to safety in
california
twelve major blazes are burning and
almost fifty thousand people have been
evacuated from their homes
cathy hodgsol has become the first
female governor of new york taking
control of the state government after
andrew cuomo stepped down over sexual
harassment allegations the democrat from
western new york was sworn in as
governor in a private ceremony overseen
by the state's chief judge
time now for the weather kirsty standing
by
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning i feel like we've been
waiting all summer for this high
pressure to take charge of the weather
across the uk and bring some fine
unsettled weather so a lovely end to
august and it's looking good right into
the start of september we have got for
many a dry start this morning there's
some overnight cloud and mist and fog
around that should soon lift and break
and then plenty of sunshine across the
uk and ireland a little bit more cloud
at times through parts of yorkshire over
towards wales maybe the old spot of
drizzle but really it's a dry day and
warm in the sunshine we're up to the low
20s 23-24 a little bit cooler in the
breeze towards northern and eastern
coast it'll be a dry night tonight and
then tomorrow we do it all over again
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
actually thanks very much uh still to
come on the program after five long
years the wait is finally over we'll be
taking a look ahead to today's
paralympics opening ceremony in tokyo
[Music]
as you get younger your risk of getting
seriously ill with covet go down
and this is why we're taking a very
cautious approach to this in this
country we're not rushing forward to
give vaccine routinely to all healthy
children because we want to be sure that
there's a clear benefit
over the risk
ratio and that we're not going to be
doing more harm than good we're very
confident that for first doses for
healthy 16 and 17 year olds that
benefit risk ratio is overwhelmingly in
favor of receiving that first dose but
people can be reassured that we're
taking this cautiously we're not rushing
forward and we very much don't want to
be in a position of later discovering we
made the wrong decision so uh the the
benefits are clear for the first days
for this age group we will be looking
very carefully before taking any further
steps into younger children or second
doses
i don't think we're going to see as many
young people receiving the vaccine as
the elderly old folks like me were
living in fear of covid with very large
numbers of serious cases emissions and
deaths and clearly as you come down
through the age groups you see those
rates coming down
but nevertheless i think we can be
optimistic that the majority of young
people will want to receive the vaccine
and of course we don't have compulsory
vaccines in this country people don't
have to have them if they don't want
them
and we will see some people not coming
forward but it will contribute to the
effort to bring this pandemic to to an
end if a majority of people do receive
this vaccine and i think that's what
we're going to see
[Applause]
i'm never lazarus and i'm skies reporter
based in delhi
we take you to the heart of the story
that shapes our world
[Music]
and not only design but biology to
create new materials which actually are
fully sustainable and biodegradable
because of provide there is a mass
increase of single-use plastics being
discarded so for me it seemed like a
great opportunity to have a material
which didn't have a longevity of plastic
but could degrade back into the earth
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back after five long years of
waiting the stage is finally set for the
world's greatest paralympic athletes in
tokyo the games begin today with the
opening ceremony at midday uk time and
over the next 12 days team gb will be
looking to build on their haul of
147 medals in rio
joining us now from tokyo nbc's sports
reporter heather cox heather great to
see you this morning you and everyone
else there must be desperately excited
five long years since the paralympics
but of course like the olympics taking
place against the backdrop of covid19
indeed there is a definite era of
excitement here i'm standing in front of
the tokyo aquatic center where swimming
takes place tomorrow but today it's all
about opening ceremony which will take
place at olympic stadium at 8 o'clock
local time here in japan the event
lasted or scheduled to last about four
hours um as always it will be a secret
who's going to light that paralympic
cauldron but what i can tell you is who
will be the flag bearers for team gb
swimmer ellie simmons and archer john
stubbs will get the honor tonight now
john stubbs did lose his father back in
january and said he thinks that his dad
would be so proud of this achievement
and he would say do it for the sub
family you have worked for this you've
earned it and you deserve it now another
interesting note tokyo is making history
is becoming the first city to host the
paralympic two times they hosted back in
1964. back then there are about
375 athletes competing this year
4 400 athletes competing
also to note for tonight at the olympic
at the paralympic opening ceremony the
afghanistan flag will be on display in
the opening ceremony even though the
athletes were not able to get here to
attend and compete
andrew person the ipc president saying
we're doing it as a sign of solidarity
well heather you enjoy yourself over the
next 12 days hopefully we'll speak again
soon thanks very much for joining us
now let's take ourselves back to our top
story the prime minister chairing an
emergency meeting of g7 nations today
where is expected to try to persuade
president biden to delay the 31st of
august deadline for the afghan
withdrawal in the last half an hour i
asked the defense secretary ben wallace
whether he thinks there's any chance the
evacuation mission could continue into
next month
i think it is an unlikely it is
definitely worth us all trying and we
will
and we've also changed internally within
our own military system uh how quickly
it could take for us to get out because
for every hour we can squash the
military evacuation is an hour we can
add on to help the civilian evacuation
as we get closer to the deadline
i think this it's correct to say that
the security risk goes up it just gets
more and more dangerous as sort of
add-on groups and other terrorist groups
such as isis would like to to be seen to
take greater credit or like to be seen
to chase uh the west at the airport that
is inevitably gonna feed their narrative
and their their ambitions uh the taliban
actually are controlling the outer ring
uh off the airport and indeed
checkpoints for kabul that makes it
harder for isis terrorists and the
taliban and isis have uh no friendly
relationship at all but yeah that we are
very mindful that we're very very
uh vulnerable should these terrorists
choose to do
and something bring in our political
correspondent tomorrow morning tc
it does seem unlikely given that which
we've just heard from the defence
secretary that it's unlikely that we're
going to see any extension absolutely
and it's not just about boris johnson
persuading the u.s president even though
he has the french and the germans as
well saying that they would like a bit
more time it's about as the defense
secretary was saying the viability of
the whole thing given that we know that
when the americans pull out of the
airport everyone else is going to have
to as well because they control all the
operations there and as he was saying
the taliban have been pretty
uncompromising the conditions on the
ground could get very difficult and
you've got other actors there they've
got an islamic state affiliate who he
said would love to have an attack on the
west and send them packing so he says
it's a trade-off between pulling out at
the very last second and potentially
leaving equipment there or accepting
that as he said yesterday there are
hours not days and we're still some 1
000 british passport holders to go and
of course thousands of desperate afghans
queuing at those gates not everyone is
going to get out but they're really
stepping up the pace now tomorrow we
will speak again throughout the show for
now thanks very much
now as the taliban approached the
presidential palace in kabul the
country's president of seven years
ashraf ghani made his getaway to the
united arab emirates his decision to
leave has brought him intense criticism
from other afghan politicians joining us
now on the programme is dr omar zakhawal
afghanistan's former ambassador to
pakistan and the country's
former finance minister doctor great to
have you on the program this morning
let us start shall we with uh with mr
ghani were you in any way surprised by
his decision like the americans to cut
and run so quickly
personally not really because i knew him
unfortunately
prior to to to that departure for the
past many years
um
when i parted away with him uh i've
raised my voice um that
it was going to lead to this crisis the
way he was managing the government the
way he was managing peace
um and
the differences between what what what
what he spoke in what he did
at the end
he completed
his tenure with that shameful act of
of departure of running away uh in
leaving the country
i think we may just have lost the line
to kabul there uh oh in fact nobody i
i'm sorry doctor zachary we just lost
you just for a second there um obviously
you are speaking to us from kabul i i
just wonder you were you were talking
about the former president there can you
just give us an idea of the conditions
that he has left the country and the the
the way in which the taliban have been
operating in and around where you are
well
he's left the country um
in a deeper crisis he's left
the country
in a situation where um
of course we need to find out
how we are going to put things back
together um to give it to normalcy um
the situation in the
airport
um
in which thousands of people are trying
to
leave
this much
or at diverse minimum this must be
stopped
um there shouldn't be such a panic such
as fear
um and that's why i was traveling out of
the country when this happened and when
i saw those pictures at the airport i
immediately decided to return to kabul
i'm in kabul i'm in touch with the
taliban i'm talk with the very few
political leaders um um such as former
president ahmed khan dr abdullah we are
clearly coordinating
we need to
the good thing is that you know we see a
flexibility um
in moderate behavior within the taliban
and we need to take maximum advantage of
that we see a desire within the taliban
for a government
that is inclusive
this country's stability of course we
need to push them more on that
and that's what we will be doing in the
days ahead
and i hope that it will be a result
to what extent i mean you mentioned from
president uh but to what to what extent
can voices like his
like yours
you you affects the the decisions taken
by the political leadership of the
taliban given
clearly there is a a real urge a real
push from the taliban to secure the
country to secure its borders and and of
course to see the back of the americans
and the british well within the next few
days
well the pastors and the taliban know
very well that taking over kabul many
times
was not
difficult it happened it is
but then to continue in governance is
not that easy um
with very sort of um
narrow mindset
or
manipulation of power um we've seen
jaiden couldn't do it the communists
could not do it and the taliban did not
do it
in the past 20
when we ended up with that um so they
know that um and we're trying to remind
that in and it's it's it's not about
that they have it all and therefore they
should keep it um
they
it's it's a conversation about the
future um
and in the sustainability uh the
government here of which there will be a
significant part um and they're
listening no doubt about it and we hope
um that at the end we will have a
government-based settlement
um not unity uh announced by the taliban
and that we hope
will be a government that will be um
they could hold that could raise that
could attract international it could
attract international assistance
entirely needed in this country because
the economy is indeed a dire
situation right now the humanitarian
crisis is emerging in this country and
that needs international support the
international presence
in afghanistan and but that to be
attracted it needs a government that's
acceptable to the international
community as well and and i do believe
the taliban understand that
dr omar zaka well thank you so much for
joining us on the program really
appreciate your time
coming up after the break i'll be
speaking to the former royal marine in
kabul who says he's been abandoned by
the government after we put his case to
the defense secretary just a little
earlier this hour that's next
[Music]
this monastery is under the protections
of russian peacekeepers
i'm dyna magne and i'm sky's russia
correspondent based here in moscow
they can't arrest everyone
[Music]
[Music]
now a former royal marine says that he
has been let down by the government as
he remains stranded in kabul he says one
of his staff members who is pregnant was
evacuated and is now stuck in terrible
conditions in germany
uh let us bring in uh paul or penn uh
farthing uh from kabul penn good to see
you this morning and clearly the
situation uh at your end will be
concerning
you allege that there was a a flight
that was blocked by the ministry of
defense coming to rescue you rescue your
staff rescue your animals i just want to
play you the response that the defense
secretary gave to me just a little bit
earlier in the program and then we'll
get you to respond just have a listen to
what mr wallace had to say
then farthing is a british possible
holder and has done an amazing thing in
kabul he he was offered a flight out i
think last friday or certainly he was
called forward to the airport for
processing his own wife i think left
about the same time
and exit the country and that is our
strong advice to him is to
leave the country um no one is blocking
the charter flight that people have
raised money
other than the fact it this is not about
flights on the ground
and whether or not
penn can get on the flight this is
simply not about you know if that
aircraft flew in today it would probably
sit there it would block the airfield it
would sit there empty because it's about
getting as i said earlier the flow
through
the gate through the barriers and into
the airport and onto
the aircraft
pen the the argument from from mr
wallace who carry went on to say i'm not
prepared to prioritize pets over people
it's not a question about getting the
flight in it's a question of getting
people to the airport your response
mr wallace um i never asked you to
prioritize pets over people at no point
have i ever said that
whatsoever
and
we've got a flight and we've said we
will wait
you've just got to give us this call
sign so we can actually get it in play
we can get the um airline to actually
start the flight plans and then we will
sit quite happily and wait
we've got an aircraft that we need to
put 69 people on it's got capacity for
250 people
and in that cargo hold you'll be empty i
can't pop people in the cargo hold but i
can pop
my animals in that cargo hold little
animals like ewok and there's going to
be absolutely no commitment from the
british military to help me do that i
just need this isaf bullseye number and
also i'd like to point out that whilst
the prime minister has actually given
and said that our staff have been
granted their
visas to travel to england i've got
absolutely no confirmation i've got
nothing in writing so if i get stopped
at a taliban checkpoint with them
they'll get turned around
and he absolutely knows mr wallace that
i said i'm not leaving here without my
staff
so i'm not going to go to the airport
and just go on an airplane so that his
problem goes away that's not going to
happen
i served my country for 22 years and the
mod has cancelled my emergency line that
i had so that i could get updates on the
situation and let them know updates he
has abandoned me here in afghanistan and
wants me to go quiet not gonna happen mr
wallace not on my watch you're dealing
with the wrong person pen so sorry to
interrupt pen but i just i just want to
kind of reiterate the point that the
defense secretary is waking that it's
not about seats on planes or the the
availability of those it is about the
crush that is taking place outside the
airport and the inability that are
thousands of people already waiting
there and the inability of people to to
get through to get to the airport that
if your plane did arrive there would be
no way of guaranteeing that anyone would
be able to get on it
getting into the airport the british
government can't help me with it that's
my problem
i'll be in the airport and i shall be
there with my staff and with my animals
and if he doesn't allow me to get on
that aircraft then i will have to park
all of my dogs and cancer sleep on the
runway
so i'm going to get into that airport
so he can't what's he going to tell me
not to now
he's just told me to get to the airport
and i'm taking my staff from animals
with me um it's that simple
i'm not being dictated to
by an mp just because he actually has
completely failed this operation to get
people off the ground we are going to
end up leaving people behind
this whole thing is absolutely just a
disaster so i'm getting to that airport
and i shall be in there with my people
my staff and the animals and we've got a
flight we need a nice half call sign if
he doesn't bring that to us then he'll
be leaving us at that airport um i'm
absolutely disgusted with him i can't
believe
i can't believe he just said that just
now he's picked on the wrong person i'm
not backing down
no way never penn pen we're about we're
about to run out of time but i just want
to squeeze in one final question again
the point that the defense secretary
makes is look air space
needs to be prioritized air traffic
control and and the number of the number
of planes on the ground need to be
controlled
you can't simply just fly into kabul
international airport these days given
the security situation outside the
cordon he does want to get you and your
staff sorry
there are charter flights arriving into
this airport
if america can do it why can't britain
i'm not taking these excuses
absolutely not and i've just seen images
of a car being flown out of afghanistan
if that's true
they're rescuing cars you've got to be
joking me sorry no
i'm not backing down he's picked on the
wrong person it's not going to happen
i'll be in that airport with my staff
and with my animals i need my flight to
be able to land if other
peop we do hope that you and your staff
stay very well indeed very well very
safe uh hopefully we'll speak again soon
uh take care and thanks for joining us
all right thank you appreciate that
thank you